bonjour et bienvenue dans cette vidéo en
collaboration avec rafi de la chaîne
sweet berry mais beaucoup du jeu parce
qu'on va parler des bibliothèques et des
bibliothèques il faut pas parler oui non
mais attends va arrêter les bêtises tout
de suite
à l'époque on pouvait parler très fort
et on pouvait même débattre dans les
bibliothèques
on va faire ça d'accord ouais bref on va
vous parler des bibliothèques avec rafi
en mettant à contribution nos
connaissances respectives dans pour deux
vidéos une ici qui parlera d'histoire
avec un petit peu de symbolique dedans
et sur ma chaîne enfin le vert sombre un
symbolique avec un petit peu 10 secondes
et ça on vous en reparlera en fin de
vidéo
[Musique]
le mot bibliothèque vient du grec et
signifie d'abord l'armoire du livre
juste le meuble avant de désigner par
extension la pièce où se trouve le
meuble au moyen-age on préfère parler
d'art mario qui désigne l'armoire où se
trouvent les livres ou encore libres are
you qui désigne l'armoire vous avez
compris de la apparaissent les mots
armario ce qui désigne la personne en
charge et livre est libre à rioux ce qui
peut désigner les moines copistes le mot
bibliothèque enfin s'impose seulement
18e siècle seulement si on commence par
l'antiquité
ce qui paraît logique la bibliothèque
d'alexandrie est la référence il parlera
à tout le monde mais ce n'est pas du
tout la première pour qu'il y ait des
livres il faut de l'écriture qui
apparaît en egypte et en mésopotamie
vers 5000 avant jésus-christ et dès le
milieu du ivème siècle apparaissent les
premiers dépôts de textes qui sont
plutôt des archives à tablettes et
autres papyrus il n'y a pas d'idée de
conservation l'intérêt de ces dépôts est
plutôt pratique et sert à une poignée de
screens et de hauts dignitaires qui sont
capables de lire
on peut quand même citer la bibliothèque
du roi assyriens assoumani pâle qui
comptait environ 30000 tablettes dont
certaines parlant de littérature de
religion de sciences de divination en
egypte l'écriture est aussi réservé au
palais et aux scream
donc on trouve surtout des bibliothèques
dans les temps on les appelle maison du
livre et dans les palais quand elles ont
une vocation plus universel en traitant
aussi de littérature de science en ayant
des ateliers d'écriture on les appelle
maison de vie on trouve par exemple la
bibliothèque royale de gizeh dès le
milieu du troisième millénaire avant
jésus-christ avec les grecs et surtout
les philosophes grecs la littérature se
développe
platon fond d'une académie aristote
aussi et on en arrive à alexandrie super
centre financier culturel de place to be
ou hey fondé le musée
ouais la bibliothèque s'appelle le musée
en fait la demeure des muses on y trouve
des professeurs des copistes des
chercheurs des oeuvres d'art son but est
de conserver un exemplaire de chaque
oeuvre existantes dans le monde
rien que ça de préférence en grec est
dans la meilleure traduction possible
d'où la présence des copistes elle
aurait possédé jusqu'à 700 mille
exemplaires ainsi que des tables de
classification permettant de se
retrouver montrant que son but n'était
pas seulement de posséder tous les
livres mais aussi d'en permettre l'accès
à ce qu'il voulait tout ça fait
d'alexandre et un centre financier avec
d'autres dépôts de livres spécialisés
mais qui sont détruits au fur et à
mesure par des incendies dont l'un est
déclenchée par césar veni vedi vici et
aussi par des troubles politiques dont
le dernier au septième siècle correspond
à la conquête arabe qui achève de
disperser et de faire disparaître cette
somme monumentale de connaissances les
bibliothèques sont aussi variées dans le
réel que dans la fiction
certaines sont à taille humaine et
d'autres sont dignes de l'eau l'un ça
tombe bien parlons des bibliothèques
utilise le style architectural de
l'antiquité dans les films déjà on peut
remarquer que ce sont plus souvent les
films américains qui ont ce type de
bâtiment il y aura forcément des contre
exemples comme dans indiana jones et le
temple maudit mais pour les us la notion
de mémoire est vraiment très importante
et c'est surtout sa différence avec
notre vision celle du vieux continent la
nation américaine et entendez la les
immigrés du vieux continent a besoin de
reconnaître sa propre valeur n'est bien
plus tard dans l'histoire est là comme
une sorte de complexe vis-à-vis de
l'histoire plus longue du vieux
continent et ça se comprend
construire de tels bâtiments pour garder
la mémoire de ce nouveau pays permet aux
us de renouer avec l'histoire mondiale
souvent qu'ils ont dû abandonner pour la
plupart d'entre eux des bâtiments
possédant des colonnes grecques des
chapiteaux romans qui semble tout droit
sorti d'un ensemble de temples liée à
une divinité s'est montré la puissance
du savoir de la ville ce genre de
bâtiment c'est aussi l'assurance du
clinquant de la force et du prestige des
symboles qui sont souvent liées à
l'antiquité ces bâtiments impose par
leur stature ils sont gigantesques par
rapport au reste via les grecs la
culture du livre s'est répandu à rome
toutes les maisons distinguer doivent
posséder une bibliothèque même dans les
villas de campagne et confisqué des
livres après une bataille est la base
même si au final c'est le biotech reste
restreinte à la famille et aux amis
sénèque dénonce même ce goût pour les
livres qui ont fait grimper les prix à
cause de collectionneurs biche mais
ignorant qu'ils n'iront probablement
jamais le premier à imaginer une
bibliothèque publique à rome et jules
césar
elle est fondée en 39 avant jésus-christ
est suivie d'autres fondations des
empereurs suivant fréquenter une
bibliothèque devient alors banal on peut
même y emprunter des livres mais elle
reste quand même réservé à ceux qui ont
déjà une bonne formation intellectuelle
à l'époque pas question de chuchoter on
trouve dans ses bibliothèques des salles
de spectacles discute travaillons débat
mais à cause de destruction et de la
fragilité des papyrus la plupart des
connaissances que renfermé ces
bibliothèques ont été perdus mais
passons au moyen âge l'arrivée de
peuples barbares en occident occasionne
de nombreuses destructions et l'arrivée
du christianisme fait que le quelques
bibliothèques comme celle de ces arrêts
ou de bethléem sens surtout consacrée
aux livres religieux les premiers mois
ne voient d'un mauvais oeil le fait de
posséder beaucoup de livres fin d'un
mauvais oeil le fait de posséder
beaucoup de quoi que ce soit toute façon
et il faut attendre le sixième siècle
pour qu'une bibliothèque dans le style
de celle d'alexandrie réapparaissent il
s'agit de la bibliothèque de vivariums
qui rassemble une centaine de manuscrits
légèrement revu les ambitions à la
baisse dont certains écrits grecque
quelle recopie le catalogue de vivario
il devient la référence à posséder dans
chaque bibliothèque
les moines commence à posséder des
livres et à développer des ateliers de
copiste à partir du 10e siècle usage de
l'écrit se développe un peu dans
certaines professions faisons aussi un
petit point arabo musulman puisque
certaines grandes villes comme bagdad le
caire cordoue mêmes tombouctou dans
l'actuel mali ont de très importants
bibliothèque qui inspire à leur tour
l'occident c'est en voyant celle de
tunis pendant une croisade que
saint-louis décide de faire son copieurs
et d'en avoir une aussi dans son palais
certains auteurs antiques sont aussi
redécouvert aux 10e et 11e siècle via
leur traduction par les arabes dans la
deuxième moitié du moyen-age on a donc
plusieurs types de bibliothèques les
bibliothèques dans les abbayes on trouve
des livres des moines et des copistes ne
touche joyeusement rassemblés dans le
scriptorium sur lequel on reviendra
juste après les bibliothèques princière
qui connaissent un grand engouement à
partir de charles 5 qui développe
énormément concept en se dotant de 3900
livre et qui inspire d'autres princes à
avoir leur propre bibliothèque
les ducs de bourgogne par exemple pour
ne pas les citer et puis certaines
bibliothèques privées plus petit chez
les juristes les médecins des
bibliothèques universitaires en tout cas
ce qu'il faut retenir du moyen-âge c'est
que les âges du livre se répondent un
peu même s'il reste très cher et que la
quasi exclusivité des livres religieux
prend fin en profite auteurs antiques et
arabes
c'est maintenant le moment de casser
toutes les images que vous aviez
probablement en tête quand je vous
parlais de scriptorium de copiste et de
bibliothèque puisque c'est le thème les
salles avec des pupitres les livres
partout les toiles d'araignées dans les
coins n'apparaissent pas avant le 13 ème
siècle et encore pour les toiles
d'araignées c'est pas sourcées
nombre de livres possédée par un
monastère est tellement faible qu'il
n'est pas dans les usages d'avoir une
salle à part la sorbonne par exemple est
l'une des bibliothèques les plus
développés au 14e siècle et possède 3
138 livres consultables 1728 dans ses
registres dont 302 carré perdu les
collections européennes pouvaient
compter une centaine de livres milles
dans le meilleur des cas
alors qu'à côté de ça les collections
chinoises avaient jusque 100 mille
rouleau n'a pas passé sur cette chaîne
alors big up à la civilisation chinoise
dans ces conditions la bibliothèque et
le coin où on range les livres en
général un coffre où les livres sont
enveloppés dans des couvertures ou plus
tardivement une armoire en bois
idem pour les collections privées qu'on
installe pas non plus tous les livres au
même endroit certains sont dans l'église
pour la messe d'autres dans le
réfectoire pour la lecture et le reste
dans le cloître où on installe les
copistes dans un coin avec le
développement des collections la
situation évolue au xiiie siècle ont
créé une salle des livres qui est
accessible uniquement aux
bibliothécaires et un scriptorium pour
les copies ce qui est souvent dans une
salle élevé pour protéger les livres et
les moines de l'humidité prévenus - de
l'humilité c'est surtout les livres mais
en fait ils avaient trop froid dans
l'autre c'est ce type de scriptorium
qu'on retrouve dans le nom de la rose
même si sa salle des livres est un peu
hors normes personne n'a le droit d'y
entrer sauf le bibliothécaire et son
assistant et une partie des livres et
stockés directement dans le scriptorium
sur des pupitres les pupitres n'était
pas seulement des meubles de travail
mais servait aussi de rangement à partir
du 13ème siècle les livres y étaient
souvent enchaîné pour éviter les vols vu
leur valeur et certains donateurs posée
même l'enchaînement des livres comme
condition pour offrir leurs livres à la
bibliothèque même une grande
bibliothèque comme celle du vatican
fondée au xvème siècle possède pour tous
rangement des armoires des coffres et
des pupitres pas de rayonnages ni
d'échelle pour y accéder désolé dans des
dystopies en science fiction qui se
déroulent dans des temps futurs on peut
souvent voir des bibliothèques qui tombe
en ruine
c'est un message fort la mémoire se perd
dans la déchéance du monde et donc de
celle des humains et des humaine après
c'est sûr qu'entre sauver ta peau contre
des zombies ou des aliens
ou sauver une bibliothèque le choix
évident vu la mémoire que la
bibliothèque garde est souvent une
représentation de ce que doit être la
civilisation
si on ne garde pas la mémoire alors il
n'y a pas de civilisation bon c'est un
point de vue un peu réducteur mais on le
trouve très souvent on reste dans la
notion de victoire contre la sauvagerie
de la nature c'est souvent là où le
héros ou l'héroïne trouve la réponse à
une énigme
il ya un symbole qui s'attache très
facilement à la bibliothèque et c'est
celui du savoir sans limite
il existe des bibliothèques
labyrinthique qui conserverait
l'entièreté des savoirs du monde dans le
nom de la rose la biotech qui est
représenté et labyrinthique et l'on
comprend très vite que cette
bibliothèque est spécial et qu'elles
renferment des ouvrages hors norme
[Musique]
cela revient à cette volonté de dompter
la nature c'est à dire de pouvoir
conserver tous les savoirs depuis la
nuit des temps le souvenir humain ne
sera jamais perdu enfin c'est ce qui est
espérée au milieu du 15ème siècle
appareils nouveautés dont vous avez
peut-être entendu parler l'imprimerie
cette invention n'est pas retenti sent
tout de suite parce que son premier but
est de reproduire des manuscrits avant
de créer de nouveaux livres uniquement
imprimer les princes continue de
préférer les manuscrits parce que c'est
plus classe et leurs bibliothèques sont
remplies de livres imprimés plus par des
dons que par des achats qu'ils font à
même les imprimés de domine
définitivement qu'à la fin du xviie
siècle les abbayes et les lecteurs privé
par contre on achète un peu plus
rapidement parce que c'est pas cher
c'est à partir de cette époque apparaît
une nouvelle forme de bibliothèques
privées chez les humanistes qui
constituent de nouvelles bibliothèque
bien fournie et invite tous leurs amis à
venir les consulter parce que jusque là
l'idée de partage des connaissances
n'était pas hyper présente
fernand colons par exemple le fils de
christophe colomb constitue une
bibliothèque privée de 15 mille livres
et reçoit même un don royal pour
l'entretien de cette bibliothèque alors
que c'était une initiative privée à la
base certaines villes florence la
première reprennent cette idée à la fin
du 14ème siècle un groupe d' humaniste
locaux fond d'une bibliothèque publique
une vraie dans le reste de l'europe
certains princes ouvrent leurs
bibliothèques aux lecteurs et savants
qui voudraient consulter les livres même
si je doute que le premier pécore venu
et auraient été vus d'un mauvais les
choses changent aussi au niveau du
mobilier au moyen-age on n'avait pas
beaucoup livre mais prenez la place sur
un mètre de longueur on pouvait poser
trois manuscrits à plat pour pas les
abîmer
alors qu'on peut facilement mettre de 20
à 40 livres debout et à ce que plus de
se péter du coup adieu coffre et bonjour
hamoir à la fin du xvième siècle
apparaissent et bibliothèque a ce talent
en angleterre dont oxford cambridge
offre un très bon exemple
mais dans le reste de l'europe on adopte
le système murale la plus ancienne
bibliothèque de ce style et l'escorial
construite à la fin du xvième siècle la
première grande pièce tapissée de livres
placés dans des armes en grillage et
pour éviter les vols
mais pour la première fois on voit les
livres les rayonnages bureau
apparaissent rapidement et avec eux les
échelles ou galeries intermédiaires tels
que toutes les bibliothèques ancienne
que vous avez déjà vu extra
[Musique]
vous constaterez si vous avez bien suivi
que je me suis arrêté au xviie siècle
si vous voulez connaître la fin de
l'espoir des bibliothèques je vous
conseille d'aller sur la vidéo de raffi
où on parlera des bibliothèques moderne
et de leurs serveurs au cinéma et si
vous avez regardé cette vidéo en
deuxième bravo vous savez maintenant
tout sur les bibliothèques et vous
pouvez travailler auprès de vos amis est
la conclusion en impro du coup ça va je
parlais assez forte un convoi remercie
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je vous
invite à aller sur la chaîne de raffi à
vous abonner à nous deux mais des
pousses b12 des commentaires à venir des
mois au revoir
[Musique]
à tous les fruits bref on a décidé avec
avec ce trafic
je suis pas magazine publie tu rates tu
lis oui pouvait on se retourne encore
hot hot hot hot hot hot hot hot hot hot
hot toutes les grandes maisons dans la
maison distingue distinguer via les
grecs la clôture durée turgis pas
comment on dit judy wade avait créé date
précise mais pour faire un livre comme
la bible qui compte environ 1000 pages
il faut 250 moutons et des mois voire
des années de travail
c'est pour ça que ouais ça semble en
disant je me suis dit fallait faire
coureurs des moutons c'était notre côté
parce que je suis une fois imprévisible
coûteux voire honteux à la fin du xviie
siècle par exemple la ville soit à la
fin du xviie siècle par exemple j'avais
parce que je pense que la vitre si vous
voulez connaître la fin l'histoire des
minutes passées sur la phase d
c'est quoi vous constaterez si vous avez
bien suivi que je me suis arrêté au
xviie siècle
salut bon attention ceci il changé de
mains propres
attention cette conclusion n'est pas
conclue non conclut du gauche ça va j'ai
parlé assez fort voilà